energy ministers meeting in Brussels
today will debate the European
Commission's proposal for a transition
to a carbon neutral economy by 2050
aimed at living up to the Paris climate
Accord now Germany Europe's strongest
economy with a huge industrial base has
long committed to a green energy
transition so what does Germany's energy
mix consist of let's take a look in 2018
renewable energy made up more than a
forty percent including wind power
hydroelectric solar and biomass the
conventional energy sources still play a
big role to take nuclear power Germany
opened its first nuclear power plant 50
years ago since then the country has
relied heavily on nuclear energy which
still accounted for over 13% of
Germany's energy mix in 2018 but the
clock is ticking Germany plans to face
out nuclear power by 2022 a decision
that certainly puts fossil fields back
in focus last year coal something
Germany has plenty of accounted for
around 38 percent of Germany's energy
mix natural gas accounts for just around
7 percent now in comparison in the
European Union renewables account for
just about 30 percent of the total
energy mix nuclear energy makes up for
over a quarter and coal and gas together
about 40 percent so Germany looks well
positioned for Europe's green energy
targets but there is a catch relying on
renewables can pose a risk to energy
security
this liquid aluminium has been heated to
900 degrees Celsius it'll be used to
make thin but stable sheet metal for the
packaging and automotive industries the
smelting process consumes huge amounts
of energy it has to shine it can't look
dull you can see it here a little bit
this is kind of dull and when the
samples are like that then I know
there's a higher percentage of iron in
it that's not good more iron means lower
prices
producing aluminum through electrolysis
burns a lot of electricity enough to
power a small city for the local power
company this smelting site is therefore
the logical place to relieve stress from
the network if there's a bottleneck if
that happens it's taken off grid it's
fine as long as our electrolysis cells
don't get so cold that they shut down or
are about to shut down but we can get by
for an hour the power company pays for
the outage so there are no financial
losses at trimet aluminium but the
electricity can't be turned off
completely for more than two hours for
the entire production process has to be
shut down
many fear that might become more common
as nuclear and coal-fired plants go
offline during Germany's energy
transition
if that occurs more often in the future
due to conventional power plants going
offline then things could get pretty
hairy we would need support in the area
we wouldn't be able to solve the problem
all on our own anymore in an attempt to
be more independent the smelting plant
is also working to develop its own
energy storage systems last year it had
to temporarily shut down a times and for
more on this topic let's bring in now
andrey wolf from the hamburg Institute
of International Economics where he
heads the research area international
economics and trade good to have you
with us
so in this report we just learned that
heavy industry certainly sounds the
alarm is Germany's energy policy this
energy makes jeopardizing our energy
security I think currently it definitely
is at least in the absence of the
consistent strategy concerning the
energy system as a whole because that's
lacking at the moment I think all right
but right now we of course we can still
rely on on other energy sources the
energy transition isn't complete yet
coal certainly is a domestic and very
reliable energy source but it's also bad
for the environment and that is why
berlin plans to phase out coal power by
2038
20:38 that's 19 years from now 19 years
of harmful co2 emissions is that in line
with the EU sir
aim to be basically green as a given the
few changes phase out of nuclear energy
yes politically no alternative to it
because in Germany we need basic law
capacities in order to compensate
temporary shortages in terms of
electricity from renewables so in this
regard I think a long-term plan for
phasing out coal-fired power plants is
inevitable so what was Berlin's decision
to exit nuclear power premature no I
don't think so because there's a
widespread
opposition in Germany towards nuclear
energy especially towards the risk the
dangers related to it so I don't see
much alternative sir - or the current
approach it's a bit like we want our
cake and eat it we want to have clean
energy nuclear would be clean as long as
it's safe at the same time we stick to
coal for a while and now there's
obviously also a very controversial new
gas pipeline being built
considering that gas only plays a minor
role what is your take on Germany's role
in this controversial nordstrom -
pipeline which runs from Russia to
Germany I think gas will continue to be
an important energy carry on the future
because due to its high flexibility it's
ideal to complement temporary shortages
and fluctuations of the provision of
electricity from renewables so on this
way I think this platform is an
important project for Germany but also
for Europe as a whole if you want to be
successful in terms of our energy
transition first of all the EU strives
for clean affordable and secure energy
supply for all with an interconnected
energy grid and that across the block
how is Germany's energy mix currently
fit into the idea of an EU wide energy
Union
I think Germany is in that sense a role
model as we are very successful in
promoting the expansion of capacities of
renewables but at the same time we're
not a leader at least concerning the
integration of his renewables into an
overall strategy I think much has to be
done right now in order to secure that
the interconnectivity of different
sectors is faster between electricity on
the one hand and heating and trans but
on the other hand to make the energy
transition successful all right so
there's still a lot of work to be done
but we're on the right track that's good
news and ribald there from the Hamburg
Institute of International Economics
thank you so much
you